wow
authorities closing on a mountain lion
that spent nearly two days around a
Northwest Valley neighborhood they say
it was captured then killed good
afternoon thank you for joining us at
four I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm Christian
Casitas will question for me on why
authorities took the measures they did
today I spoke to a resident who came eye
to eye with the Wildcat and witnessed
the takedown on her property in the
Northwest Valley
[Music]
it's been a long night for Danielle
seals he was perched right on this
corner after her ring camera captured a
mountain lion outside her Sky Canyon
home it was very you know again
confident and like docile and he was
having a cat nap the wild cat was
spotted a few days earlier in the
neighborhood one resident filming this
video of it but it was on Tuesday that
seal says her fears became a reality I
went out just for a morning off and saw
the animal on my walk right above my
neighbor's house and it was literally
just had its eyes stocking on us and we
had no idea she grabbed her daughter and
her dog and quickly went inside her
house later that night her ring camera
captured the mountain lion walking
across her yard with a dead cat in its
mouth and the lion walked up my stairs
with it in its mouth and was very
comfortable in the front yard here and
so when I saw that on my ring camera I
posted it in ring and then all my
neighbors saw that it was still here in
the community another neighbor
confirming Seal's fears with a light
while the animal showed no signs of
backing away metro police were called to
the home near Farm Road and Grand Canyon
to assist there's two police outside on
the perimeter there's two police right
in front there's Queens all lined up
here there's a helicopter patrolling
just in case he moved so they can have a
spotlight on him
hours later seal says the game warden
arrived and the animal was captured they
did assure me got the shot with a
tranquilizer and that he was returned
they said I don't know if they say that
to make me feel better because I feel
terrible I knew it was gonna come as
fate naturally but I know that he also
can't roam our neighborhood
well we did reach out to the Nevada
Department of Wildlife about this case
and they tell us the animal was
euthanized because it was a public
safety measure after it refused to leave
the area when pressured